il a aimé
jacquet son chien ouais comment il
s'appelle baba bâ jusqu'à ma bague en
diamant pas bien tu écoutes permis de
faire maintenant que tu es vraiment mon
père mon patron c'est parce qu'il était
là il est aveugle non mon bébé bourru
aveugle et qu'il a 15 ans il revient du
n'est pas ça ce n'est pas laid
c'est un chèque j'ai ramené de là-bas en
80 et donc qu'il va sur ses 15 ans qui
voit ça lui fait
117 110 ans à 35 105 ans
commence à faire
non non non mais il est bien c'est
quelqu'un qui mise et yves durand le
tonnage jeudi midi balade dans pourquoi
tant qu il est bien il voit pas bon il
entend pas mais je dis ah bon et bien
chez partouche
aaa il me faut encore le plan s'arrête à
chier dans l'ascenseur te jure que
c'est interdit vous avez vu
divagations de comète de schengen
le reconnut quoi reconnait
à oui sinon je
fixe à
quai avec gucci je regrette il est
proche de karachi ah ah oui du tibet
alors
la merde eric charden elle était au
tibet aussi comme votre chien
à quoi
donc lui la halle de râler il s'appelle
jsui j'aimerais bien d'ailleurs qu'il
fasse de la pub à la place du client qui
était dushevina rus du white knight
l'enam à lui à sa place aussi pas
toujours les mêmes questions fait
attraper avec un chien ensemble
immobilier mais non non absolument pas
non non non moi je ne risque finalement
c'est plein de chiens ici c'est
incroyable non tiens ma fille que c'est
interdit
mais cherche pas les puces les change
pas les plus
bas toute heure on se revoit tout à
l'heure ne compte pas moins
un petit café chez moi mais bon votre
chien là n'est ce pas qu'il est beau
c'est quoi comme chien un boxer mélange
avec un berger belge
oh là là là là ça doit se marier ces
bêtes là bas est normalement les deux
parents 20 pedigree il n'aurait pas dû
se marier non non les en empêcher
c'était la famille angleterre voilà et
ça fait ça fait ça ça fait neuf ans que
je les
avais pas que un peu ses deux lancers de
l'arthrose avant c'est comme nous quand
on a dit on à tisme un
oui mais je donne des cachets je vais
pas encore donné je lui donnais tout à
l'heure ouais
vous faites quoi vous ben je promenais
mon chien je vais rentrer à la maison
tout simplement mais si vous voulez
venir prendre un verre pourquoi
paraissent pas dans la vie vous fait
quoi un show sur ma nouvelle idée chaud
oui en discothèque avant mais oui mais
quel disque dans toutes les discothèques
de france
ça s'appelle qu'est devenu l'ange bleu
tu as mal à la papa tu
prouves db
bien rentrer dans
la mare temps avait lâché bédié
c'est un peu comme quoi si
non c'est pas combien fréquenté il ya
beaucoup de et beaucoup de problèmes de
drogue mais apparemment ça a l'air de
s'arranger eh bien oui
beaucoup trop gay beaucoup de revendeurs
ouais mais la police a il ya mis son
aulaye ça va beaucoup mieux sans ça oui
on est bien
il vendait quand même des l'héroïne du
shit fin ils ont des taux tout et rien
enfin bon avec le chemin ben ouais ça
veut dire comment il s'appelle je sais
qu'ils bus
font rentrer lasalle-émard
que je te retire la lèze bd attend bien
je crois que j'ai coupé la télé non
attends aller alors le divan aller à
coucy son livre oui enfin cesser sa
place préférée fill ces panneaux god
c'est 10 22
comment ça fait ah c'est vous monsieur
thierry à quelque chose savaient que
dire me sont faits ou interdit aux
agents utilisés à bon pour faire la pub
est celle où j'ai dit mais ça tombe bien
parce tu sais le faire alors ils me
l'ont dit pour faire la parfaite
et elle fasse appel à miss
ennemi si elle mise à mort
si anglet au surnom mais bon
sa bonne foi
excusez vous ces chiens francs il est
beaucoup moins s'appelle il s'appelle
garçons ans garçons il a quel âge là
quatre ans après il est beau
comment gérez vous faire une espèce de
petit chien d'un bon
allez viens garçons décident d ici
quatre solistes vous oubliez un peu
toujours avant beaucoup mieux que les
femmes
qui posent pas de questions lui
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu